*Pfff !
Encore un temps à ne pas mettre un chat dehors.
Pas vrai Nitro ? T’aimes pas la pluie.
Elle préfère les « capsules de déconfiné ».
Alors reste avec moi,
je vais t’expliquer pourquoi les chats n’aiment pas l’eau.
Le chat est une espèce originaire
du Moyen-Orient et d’Afrique du Nord,
des régions très arides où les points d’eau
sont extrêmement rares.
Hormis pour boire, le chat a donc su se passer d’eau.
A l’origine, c’est un milieu qu’il ne connaît pas.
D’où sa grande méfiance quand il s’en approche
ou quand il pleut.
Alors qu’en fait, l’eau ne présente
aucun danger pour les chats.
D’ailleurs, ils savent tous nager.
D’autres félins, originaires de régions tropicales
le jaguar ou le tigre, n’éprouvent
quant à eux aucune appréhension.
Ils se baignent et chassent volontiers dans les rivières.
Tenez, il y a même des chats qui adorent l’eau.
Le Maine Coon par exemple ou bien le Turc de Van.
Celui-ci précisément parce qu’il est originaire
des rives du lac de Van, à l‘Est de la Turquie,
et qu’il a donc toujours vécu au contact de l’eau.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour éviter d’en louper,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
On va prendre un bain ?